(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
We've sold $2.9 million
worth of product.
(zaps)
(laughter)
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
Have you put up
any of your money?
(exhales) Thousands.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Kevin, he can't just sell
chopping blocks. That's boring.
Why not?
I forbid you to talk
about this topic anymore.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with Nothing.
Guys, I really do need a deal.
I can't leave without a deal.
It's sink...
(Kevin) So what are you
gonna do?
We'd like to hear if there are
any other offers.
Or swim.
Numbers never lie, David.
I'm not saying the numbers
are wrong.
What I'm saying is
you're wrong.
♪♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of qvc,
holds over a hundred patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over
a half a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold
his first internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious
billionaire entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
are Samantha Meis
and Connor Riley,
who want to make your next trip
to the coffee shop
a thing of the past.
♪♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Samantha Meis.
And I'm Connor Riley.
Our company is Mistobox,
and we are here today
seeking a $75,000
investment in exchange
for 15% equity
in our company.
Everyone loves coffee,
and our company Mistobox
is revolutionizing the way
that people discover coffee
from around the world.
More than 400 million
cups of coffee
are consumed daily
in the U.S. alone.
Coffee has never been
more popular than it is today.
Thanks to the boom
of small, local coffee shops,
we've all learned
it's the independent
artisan coffee roaster
that seeks out
the world's best beans
and artfully roasts a product
that is far superior
to anything you could find
in those big box stores
or huge national coffee chains.
But the question is,
how do we discover these coffees
to brew in our own homes?
Lori, you live in Chicago,
but let's say that
your perfect cup of coffee
is being grown
in Ethiopia,
then roasted in Tennessee.
(laughter)
How are you supposed
to find out about it?
Mistobox delivers
the world's best
undiscovered artisan coffee
to your door every single month.
Each Mistobox
is carefully packed
with four
fresh roasted coffee samples
from different mom-and-pop
coffee roasters.
We're coffee experts,
and we hand-Select
only the very best of coffees
to send to you.
After you brew
and pick a favorite,
you can head back
to our online shop,
purchase the full-size bag,
and we'll send it
straight to your door.
With free shipping!
(laughs)
We're helping these
small,
local coffee roasters
compete with the big guys
while introducing you
to amazing coffee
from around the world.
Sam's gonna pass out
some fresh brewed coffee
in our misto boxes
for you guys to enjoy.
Is it sort of like doing,
like, the brewery
or wine by the month
or something like that?
It's like
a book of the month.
Right. Right.
It's a subscription service.
Exactly, Mark.
Tell us what we have
in front of us.
So, yeah.
You guys have some coffee brewed
from next month's Mistobox.
These coffees were grown
in El Salvador,
Guatemala, Ethiopia,
and Tanzania,
then they were sourced
and roasted in Washington,
Oregon, California,
and Colorado.
Okay, So, um, coffee's good,
all right?
(Samantha) Great.
I'm trying it. It's delicious.
I'm a coffee drinker.
What's the cost of acquiring
me as your customer?
Because I've never heard
of you before,
but I may be a customer.
How are you gonna get me?
So, so far, our cost
of customer acquisition
has been $4.60.
Oh, you know that number?
Yes, we do.
It's very rare
that somebody
with an online strategy
walks in here
and knows that number.
Yep.
You get special
bonus points for that.
Very good.
I will take another
sip then.
Great.
Thank you.
(Lori laughs)
(Mark) Where are you
guys from?
We're from
Scottsdale, Arizona.
Okay. How'd you get
into this?
So, we actually met
at the University of Arizona,
and we started the company
out of
the entrepreneurship program.
Are you dating?
We are not.
No, we're not dating.
Just friends.
Did you ever date?
No, we didn't.
Never dated.
How would I hear about you?
Where are you targeting me?
So right now we're really
targeting the coffee community
and the foodie community.
We were surprised to find
that the foodie-type people,
not just the coffee people,
were really receptive to us,
because they really want
to learn more about coffee.
So we're targeting the bloggers,
all of the different
publications.
All right, so grassroots.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Walk me through
the pricing model.
I hear about you.
I say, "Mistobox."
Right. So you can go back
online...
okay.
And we have three different
subscriptions,
and then three different
gift subscriptions.
Yep, just Mistobox.Com.
What do they range
in price?
They range $15
for a monthly subscription
and $14 for 6-month
subscription
and $12.50 for
a year-long subscription.
And then what do I--
how do you charge me more?
So, if you get
a year-long subscription,
you pay $150 on day 1,
and then that equates
to $12.50 a month
and you get that
for the full year,
and then at the end
of the year,
you're recurrently billed
for the following year.
There's no other cost?
Whether I keep it, send it
back, there's--That's it?
No matter what you do.
And if you get
a monthly subscription,
it's recurring billing
until you cancel.
And on that $150--
Let's work with that example.
Right.
So it's $150.
I paid you up front.
What's your margin on that
over the year?
So our margin is anywhere
from about 30% to 45%,
and we get the coffee
from the roasters
at a steep, steep discount
or for free.
How are they giving it
to you for free?
(Mark) So then--Yeah.
Why would they give it
to you for free?
We're a sampling department.
Because we are putting
their product
in the hands
of prequalified consumers
that want to try new coffees.
So, the advantage
to the coffee guys is,
I can't get my coffee
out there.
You're offering me
a distribution channel.
(both) Exactly.
And the hope for me
as a coffee guy
is that Lori will start
buying my coffee.
(both) Exactly.
Is that right?
Right.
Does a time come
when I, the customer, says,
"Oh, that coffee from Ethiopia
is all I care about"?
you know--
"That's all I want.
Just ship me that.
"Stop the madness on
the Mistobox coming every month.
"don't want to see that
anymore.
Just send me
my ethiopian coffee"?
Mr. Wonderful, as long
as you stay our customer,
we're happy.
We'll send you
your favorite coffee
on your schedule.
So say you want it
every two weeks, every week--
Yeah, well,
that's what you said.
You just go back to
your Web site And order
whatever coffee
you like, right?
You go back to the web site,
you order that coffee,
And you can choose
the recurring schedule you want,
whether that's--
so it's an auto-delivery.
It's an auto-delivery.
auto-delivery every month.
Every month.
It ships to you
whatever you choose.
Exactly.
Yeah. And you can switch
at any time.
There's no commitment.
'cause your margins--
What percentage convert
from that?
They start on the sampler box.
What percentage go
to the full-Time--
We have about--
right now, we have about
15% of our customers
coming back online
and ordering coffee.
So we have
two revenue streams--
Both from the subscription
and from the return online
sales.
How long have you
been in business,
and what have you done
to date?
Yes, so we've been operating
for about four months now,
going into our fifth month.
And we have a growth chart
here for you guys.
We just hit
our 700 customer Mark.
So in the past 21 days,
we've grown by 370%
and about, uh,
551 customers.
So, Connor, when you say
"Customers," can I assume
that those 700 people
are buying some type
of subscription?
Exactly.
Yes, they're buying
a subscription...
(Robert) Okay.
Whether it's a monthly,
6-Month, or annual.
And what you invested
in cash so far?
We actually had--are you guys
familiar with kickstarter?
Sure. Yeah.
We had a successful
kickstarter campaign
where we raised just over
$9,000.
That's what kind of
kickstarted us,
and then we've each invested
about $6,000 of our own money.
That's it?
Just--Yeah, it's just been--
It's just us two.
Um, we've been doing this.
And you guys just box,
pack, and ship them yourselves?
We do it--Everything--
Everything ourselves.
Everything.
Web site, design...
Yeah.
What's the game plan? What are
you doing with the $75,00?
What's the plan over
the next 12 months?
So with the $75,000,
we really need to--to grow.
We're gonna need to move
into a bigger space.
We're in her 1,200-Square-Foot
apartment
where she's living
and we're working.
We obviously don't have
the room that we need.
And we also need to hire
a little bit of help.
♪♪♪
You're just a crapshoot.
Right.
All right,
here's an offer for you.
♪♪♪
All right,
here's an offer for you.
$75,000 for 25%.
Okay.
We'd like to hear if
there are any other offers.
(groans)
You didn't tell them
how many beans you want...
no, it's just a--
a month.
It's straight equity, and--
and it's either going to zero--
I've invested in subscription-
based companies before.
Some have been successful,
been acquired.
Others went to zero immediately
'cause they were run by idiots.
Okay.
I'm not sure which ones
you are yet.
We're not idiots.
We're not idiots. (laughs)
So here's what I really like
about your business.
Coffee is the number-one drug
in the world.
Exactly!
Exact--
You're getting there.
I think, uh,
you've done a great job
of finding a business...
(chuckles) That I never would
have thought existed.
I just don't see the long-term
vision of the market.
I'm not the right partner,
I don't think.
Uh, I'm out.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
I'm not a coffee drinker,
so I'm not
the right partner for you.
I wish you good luck,
but I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Thanks, Lori.
I'm--I'm not
a coffee drinker, myself.
I'm not into subscription model.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks, Daymond.
Thank you, Daymond.
Mark, you seem to know
a lot about S.E.O.
and about
the subscription model.
I-I think this might be
a good pair.
Samantha, Mark thinks he knows
everything about everything,
so...
(laughter)
So what do you think,
Mark?
I'm not all the way there yet.
Okay.
Well, what can we do
to get you there?
You can keep paying attention
to him,
who's not all the way there,
and potentially lose
the one that is
all the way there.
You know, if you know who you
want to have as an investor,
and it's Mark, do that.
I'm happy to retract my offer.
Please don't retract
your offer quite yet.
I'll give you 30 seconds,
and then
I'll take my offer back.
That should add some drama
to your lives.
Okay.
So either
you can convince Mark
to make a counteroffer--
and I'm convincible.
Okay.
So if you really wanted
to do a deal with me--
Mark, we'd love to do
a deal with you.
Mark, we would really love
to do a deal with you.
What can we do
to get you there?
Um, I need more equity even
than what Kevin offered.
Okay.
Because you're gonna
take more time...
ten seconds.
And you're gonna take
more effort from me.
If you're looking for
just the best deal--
can we ask for a standstill
and go talk in the hall?
(Lori) 30 seconds.
(Daymond) 20 seconds.
No, unfortunately, you've got
15 seconds left.
(whispers indistinctly)
♪♪♪
Okay, so you're gonna
need more equity?
Yes.
Okay.
How much more equity?
$75,000 for 30%.
How does that sound?
Done.
(Daymond) Nice.
Mark, it's a deal. Sorry!
(Daymond, Robert, and Lori)
Ohh!
Appreciate it.
Yeah, this will be
a lot of fun.
Congratulations.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Appreciate that, mark.
Thank you so much, guys.
You should really be
thanking me.
This was a great experience.
You're awesome.
I just held his little
tootsies to the fire
and helped you immensely.
Thank you, guys.
It was great meeting you.
Thanks, guys, so much.
We really appreciate it.
That was
an amazing experience.
Good luck.
All right, guys.
Thanks, guys.
So the reason that we went
with Mark at 30%
rather than Kevin at 25%
is because
Sam's got a crush on Mark,
and I like sports,
so it worked out perfect.
♪♪♪
Earlier this season,
Abby Jordan and Becky App
failed to make a deal
with the sharks
for their online ice cream
company ecreamery.
We want the capital
for a production facility.
I don't really think you need
a partner here.
Why don't you just keep
doing what you're doing?
Thank you for tasting it,
for trying it, for Loving it.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
♪♪♪
There were absolutely
some tears
after not making a deal
with the sharks.
But business is now booming,
and we're swimming in orders
instead of swimming
with the sharks.
We just got 30 more
orders of pistachio.
Before "Shark Tank,"
it took us five years
to do $2 million in sales.
Since "Shark Tank's" aired,
we have done
a half a million dollars
in sales in just three months.
We have hired
three new chefs.
We've hired a call center
to talk
to each and every customer
that comes our way.
Would you like to start out with
an ice cream or a gelato base?
We're forecasting to do
$2 million in the next year,
and by 2015, we're gonna be
a $5 million business.
Oh, this is so great.
It's bigger
than our whole store!
With the spike in sales,
we have been able to fund
our own move into
a production facility.
Absolutely perfect.
There's enough space
for really everything
we were thinking about.
We've been touring
different locations,
so we're hoping
very, very soon,
we'll have that production
facility completed.
Shark bait? All right.
Although we didn't get a deal
with the sharks,
it really taught us that
a win can sometimes be
disguised as a loss.
And now we are really
starting
to make a dent
in the ice cream business.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
is Michael J. Desanti
with a product to discourage
little thieves.
♪♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My Michael J. Desanti.
Mike D. for short.
I am seeking $130,000
in exchange
for 40% of my business.
And my business is
the squirrel boss
squirrel-proof bird feeder.
(sharks laughing)
Squirrel boss is
the world's first
interactive squirrel-Proof
bird feeder.
Now, we know squirrels
are extremely cute,
and they need to eat, too.
But they are 5-Pound gorillas,
and they are hogs!
But with squirrel boss,
if you see a squirrel
on your bird feeder,
and he wears out
his welcome,
just press the remote control
and deliver a harmless
static-shock correction.
(sharks laughing)
That is similar
to walking across the carpet
and touching something.
Buh-Bam! (laughs)
It tingles,
but it doesn't hurt you.
Who would like to challenge
the squirrel boss?
Whoo! (laughs)
You are up!
Please Come and grab
this squirrel boss.
(Robert) Mike,
can I please zap her?
You may.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
Go ahead.
Ready?
Aah!
(laughter)
You know what? I missed it.
Would you guys do it again?
Hey, big shot,
why don't you try it?
Yeah, come on, cuban!
(Lori) Yeah!
What if there's two squirrels
on it?
Okay. Ready?
That's fine.
Two squirrels!
(zap)
(laughter)
It's... (speaks indistinctly)
Kaboom!
Everybody!
Come--
Okay, I gotta try it.
You must feel this.
(laughs)
I don't feel anything.
(zap)
(high-pitched voice) Aah!
(laughter)
Daymond John, you are up!
(zap)
Aah!
(laughter)
(Lori) Come on, kev.
No, thank you!
(Robert) So, Mike--Mike D.,
just to be clear,
I'm sitting in my house.
Yes.
I see the little squirrel
eating.
Yes.
I think he's had too much.
I zap him?
That's the whole thing.
When I said
"Wears out his welcome"--
because squirrels need
to eat, too.
But that means I have to be
watching the bird feed--
That's
our second-Biggest objection
that I get all of the time
in public and--
What's the first?
That you have to be watching--
It's too expensive,
and that's why I'm here.
I have a question. Let's say
the squirrel, named Joe...
(chuckles)
goes on, gets zapped.
Does Joe then never
come back again?
And how many shocks
can Joe take?
No, excellent question,
Lori.
Um... it gets Boring
really fast.
Boring?
Boring, meaning he won't
touch it after two shocks.
Oh, he won't touch it?
He won't touch it.
But, Mike, wouldn't
the animal rights people
get all over this?
You're el--
You're electrocuting
the animals.
Actually, they like it,
because they know
the alternative is lethal force.
People are, unfortunately,
shooting squirrels to death.
There's no way to stop
an animal--
Is that legal?
It's totally legal,
totally unethical.
There's a squirrel rehabilitator
in massachusetts.
Squirrel rehabilitator?
If he finds squirrels
that were orphaned,
for whatever reason,
he'll nurse the baby squirrels
with a bottle till they're
well enough to go away.
(laughs)
And you know what?
He said to me--
he said, "Mike D., I would not
own your bird feeder,
but I like it, because I know
the alternative is terrible."
Mike, is there
a business here?
Tell--Tell me
the business side of it.
Let's get serious here.
Okay.
We have sold $196,096.
It was 4,131 units.
Average wholesale price--
$47.47 per Unit.
How much money have you
put into it so far?
I had an Angel investor.
How much did he put in?
$140,000.
Really?
How much have you
paid him back?
All but $38,000.
Good for you.
And I'd be in the black
right now,
but we spent $60,000
on "Traditional marketing"
That didn't work.
Have you put up
any of your money?
I--a lot of my money,
and...
how much?
Thousands.
Not tens of thousands.
Do you have a patent on it?
Unfortunately, the--I had
the worst patent attorney
on planet earth.
He was older than dirt.
He was 15 years behind
the current state of the law,
so it was denied.
We chose not to appeal--
was it denied because something
else existed already like it?
No, no, no.
It says, "As seen on tv."
Does that say that on there?
It--it does, because
the news crew came to my house.
So it was a news story
on tv.
Oh, so it's a quasi--
(laughter)
It's not a real "As seen on Tv."
Well, in business, you...
it's a--It's a--
(laughter)
It's a imitation.
♪♪♪
(Robert) Mike,
here's my challenge with it.
Sure.
I see it as a quirky product.
You'll sell some.
You'll make a little bit
of money.
But I wouldn't quit
my day job today.
Good for you for inventing it,
but, uh, I don't want
to get zapped again.
I'm out.
Well, thank you.
I appreciate that,
but I strongly disagree.
This, uh, pays for itself
with the seed you save.
It's fun every time.
It's saving the lives
of millions of squirrels.
Mike, here's my thought.
To me, to zap a squirrel--
That's a little sadistic.
For that reason, I'm out.
Guys, I really do need
a deal.
I can't leave without a deal.
You know what, Mike?
It's not a product that
I'm gonna put my heart into.
I'm just not a squirrel
whisperer, so I'm out, Mike.
I'm really sorry to hear that.
(Kevin) This may shock you,
Mike.
I'm out.
I'm not shocked, but I
appreciate that. Thank you.
So only Damon's left, I think.
♪♪♪
I'm out.
I can't leave.
I won't leave.
You know what?
Put your hand on that.
Give me that button.
You'll be gone soon.
(sharks laughing)
Okay. Thank you.
(Daymond)
Thank you so much.
(Lori) Good luck.
Okay, have a good day.
Good luck. You're very clever.
(Robert) You know what? I think
the squirrels get on there
with their little hands
and go, "Bah!"
Oh, for sure. For sure!
And fall
right on the ground!
I bet you if you went up
to that squirrel
and held a hazelnut
in front of it afterwards,
he'd have no idea
what he was looking at.
(laughter)
I really, really, really wanted
one of the sharks as my partner.
I like all of the sharks
in their own way--Even Kevin.
♪♪♪
Next up is David Glickman,
who grew a hobby
into a full-fledged business.
♪♪♪
Hello, sharks.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is David Glickman,
and I am the proud owner
of the Vermont Butcher Block
& Board Company.
I'm here seeking $400,000
for 25% equity stake
in my business.
We make the most awesome
and beautiful
Kitchen products ever,
in my opinion.
My wife and I left manhattan
after We burnt ourselves out
in the rat race.
We moved to vermont to live
our lives in calmer waters.
I took off my tie
for the last time
and decided to wear tie-dye
for the rest of my life.
I became
a true Vermontrepreneur.
The bottom line--
We make
premium quality products
using
Premium quality materials,
and we charge...
premium pricing.
Can you tell I love
the word "Premium"?
I'd like to pass out
some samples.
Ladies first, of course.
Thank you.
Lori, you have one of our
premium-grade cutting boards.
It's our small size.
Robert, you have
one of our cheese boards.
Kevin, you have
a walnut salad bowl
with the tiger maple rim.
Thank you.
Daymond, you have one of
our medium-sized cheese trays.
And, Mark, you have
our salad server.
So you've seen the product.
You've heard the spiel.
Who wants to join
the tie-dye tribe?
What's the tie-dye about?
Very good question.
When I quit the rat race,
I lived in New York City.
Yes.
I burnt myself out.
I said, "That's it.
I'm gonna wear tie-dye
for the rest of my life."
It was just a sign
of freedom for me.
I don't care if you wear
goat skin.
I want to know if you make
any money.
(laughter)
We are making money,
Kevin.
Okay.
Great question.
Uh, to date,
we've sold $2.9 million
worth of product.
Whoa!
Over what period of time?
I started in 2004.
Last calendar year,
we sold $800,000.
This year, we're s--
We're slated to sell
probably a million,
a million 50.
What are you gonna make
on that million dollars?
Uh, we're running about 20%.
What do you need us for?
I need money,
and I need somebody
who knows business
to help me grow the business.
You're, uh, asking for 25%
for $400,000.
That's around $1.6 million
you are valuing the business at.
And you made a profit
of $150,000 last year.
Yeah.
I figured one and a half
times sales.
Why did you figure that?
Let me go through my client--
My client list.
Daniel boulud
is our number-One client.
We have our retail store--
We have one retail store
up in vermont
where we can sell
all of our odds and ends
and we can test-market
our product.
It does about $400,000
a year.
Wow.
Internet, which is about
10% of our business.
Wholesale, which is about
Uh, then we have
restaurants.
And we also just started
talking to Fleming's,
which is a chain out here
that you guys probably know.
We're in the orvis catalog.
We're in the frontgate catalog.
We've talked to Williams-Sonoma
three times.
Did they give you orders,
or you talked to them?
Talked to them.
'cause I talked to guy Named
Williams-Sonoma
three times yesterday.
We was at a dice game.
Well, we talked to them.
I don't know--
but then
they approached me.
They wanted 25 Pieces
for their top 12 stores.
We couldn't make the demand.
Right now I have
a-a 2,000-Square-Foot shop
on my property.
We need to move out
to a production facility
so I can grow the business.
I can't keep selling
if I can't produce.
Why wouldn't you focus on
the one thing
that you can differentiate
yourself in being--
The best chopping block
in America,
made from the trees of vermont,
and just focus on that?
Why do you need
to make these?
He has to offer more.
Thank you, Lori.
Do you know how inexpensively
these are made in Asia?
There's thousands of them.
They are. They are.
Absolutely.
And you know what?
They crack, they drop,
they're thin, they're bamboo.
Yeah, yeah, but they sell!
They sell.
Yeah, Kevin, you can't just
offer chopping blocks.
I sell
to the premium market.
Why not?
That sells--the--
the cheap ones sell to the--
to the people that want
to walk into walmart
and pay $2.99.
Okay.
People--but people who are
giving wedding gifts
don't want to give
a $2.99 bowl.
They want a nice set
of wooden bowls. I have--
I'm trying to figure out
how you carve a niche
in your space
that is defendable.
I think by expanding your
business into all this stuff,
you're going
into some categories
where there's tremendous
competition.
No. You--You know what?
I don't normally jump in
and speak
for the entrepreneur...
thank you, Lori.
I appreciate that.
But, Kevin, he can't just
sell chopping blocks.
Why not?
It's Boring.
That's right.
Because nobody Wants
just chopping blocks
from a company.
They want a number of S.K.U.S.
He's got a retail store.
(Lori) Yeah.
What's he gonna do all of
a sudden for his retail store,
go, "I'll stop"?
forget about it--
"I could sell tie-dye."
I forbid you to talk about
this topic anymore.
David, here's where
it doesn't add up for me.
Normally,
when people want money,
it's in order to lower
their cost
and increase their margin.
Your margin is fantastic.
It is to increase
our production capability.
We're profitable. I can sell
as much product as I can make.
Well, do you need machinery,
or do you need staff?
I do.
We need space,
we need machinery,
and we probably need
more people.
Nobody's brought this up,
so I'm--
I'm gonna bring up
something...
sure.
That might be
a crushing blow.
Uh-Oh.
You're competing against--
You know,
the new wave for all things
that are cutting boards
is antimicrobial boards.
You're aware of that.
I am.
And they're extremely
popular on the market.
The whole point about it is,
is that salmonella, e. Coli,
and other types of things
will not...
okay.
Leech into the board
and therefore
contaminate your food.
That's not True.
"Cook's illustrated" Came out
with an article,
and what they found was
that plastic cutting boards
kept the bacteria on them
longer
than the wood
cutting boards did,
because wood has a natural
propensity to kill bacteria.
I think you ought to ignore
all the comments.
I get that you're trying
to grow this business.
All you need is capital.
Basically, what you're saying--
You know your stuff.
In order for me
to be effective,
it means I have to make
a commitment to learn
the Butcher block
and board industry.
I don't feel comfortable
giving advice
unless I do the Work.
Okay.
I can appreciate that.
And if anything,
I-I do that too much.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
I'm a hard worker.
I am dedicated.
I am loyal to this business.
I know it has
a potential to grow.
I really do.
You know, David,
one of the things
I really like about me
is I'm always right.
Well, you think
you're always right.
I know I'm always right.
It's important to know that,
because in your case,
my vision of your business
is different than yours.
I'd argue to you,
when you actually allocate
the time that you're spending,
selling a spoon--
It's not really profitable
at all.
You don't agree with me--
I disagree--
I disagree, Kevin. I disagree.
We need to be
at the full line--
Why do you disagree?
Because--
Numbers never lie, David.
I'm not saying the numbers
are wrong.
What I'm saying is
you're wrong.
The only reason
a business exists
is to make money.
You can be passionate
about it--
I agree. I agree.
You and I don't agree
on the next direction.
That's what happens
in the shark tank.
We don't have to.
It's your business.
But it's my money.
I'm out.
(Daymond) Dave, um,
I-I love your Passion.
Thank you.
You have a good business
for yourself.
Thank you.
You're a smart guy, but I'm
just not excited about it.
I'm out.
Sorry.
I appreciate that.
Thank you.
Well, not thank you
for being out,
but thank you
for your feedback.
David, um...
make me an offer,
Robert.
Please.
Look, I-I love--
It's a great business.
I love the story, and I think
great Businesses are built
when somebody has the passion
like you.
But here--Here's my challenge.
As an investor, to give you
a $400,000 investment,
which is 50% of today's sales,
that seems risky to me.
And I don't know enough
about your business
to share your passion in it.
I'm out.
Lori?
I'll give you
a bigger percentage.
I want a partner who can
help me grow my business.
Well...
I think your work
is beautiful.
Thank you.
And I really respect
and admire what you've done.
But I am brutally honest.
And I--my concern is
the antimicrobial boards
are really coming on strong,
and they have been for years,
and they're taking
a larger part of the market.
I agree, but you say that
with no--With No...
and--
Uh, industry knowledge
on that.
I-I do have knowledge
about it, and it's okay.
I mean, I have my feelings,
you have yours.
But for me,
it's not a good investment.
I think it's too risky,
because I don't think
that you're
with the cutting edge
of what's really happening.
And for that reason, I'm out.
♪♪♪
40%, Mark.
40%. I do everything.
That's a big change,
but it's not--
It's not my--Not my kind
of deal, David.
Sure? Daymond? 40%?
Robert, 40%.
I do all the work.
We e-Mail once a month,
you give me your input.
It--I--
45%, Robert.
I don't feel comfortable
with giving you $400,000,
which is 50% of your sales.
So go in with mark.
$200,000 apiece.
You guys each get 22.5%.
You get enough skin in the game,
and you let me grow
the business.
David, David, you're not
helping yourself.
I know. I know, but I--
I'm just--I'm trying,
because he's sitting
on the fence.
Well, David, how much
do you really want this?
Would you sell 51%
and give up the spoons forever?
He's playing you.
(Lori) Oh, don't--
No, I want to know.
I want to know.
You know what? Don't even.
I'm not that desperate.
I want a partner
that I can grow
the business with.
Don't even go there.
David, thank you.
David,
you're overselling now.
Yeah.
Call me on Monday.
Thank you, guys.
I guarantee you he makes
no money in spoons. Zero.
(laughs)
♪♪♪
Not very happy right now.
Not very happy.
I'm confident in what I do.
I'm confident
in my customer list.
I'm confident in my product,
So, you know, I'll grow
my business without them.
♪♪♪
My name is Carole Foster,
I'm from Compton, California,
and I live with my 12-year-old
daughter Courtland.
My product is
Mee-Ma's Louisiana gumbo.
My gumbo is a secret recipe
passed down to me
by my Mee-Ma,
and it's the best gumbo
You'll ever taste.
Mmm, that's really good.
(horn honks)
My family and I decided
to sell gumbo
on the street corner,
and when we realized
how popular it was,
we realized
we have something
really good going.
Don't forget
to say your prayers.
I've sacrificed a lot
for this company.
We've been through a lot
of struggles, my daughter and I.
Financially, we've gone
through a lot
where we didn't have
enough money
just to make it
through the week.
I've gotten a lot of interest
from a major grocery chain.
They want to put my gumbo
in their stores,
but I just don't have the funds
to produce the orders
and Seal the deal.
I hope the sharks
really do like gumbo.
I hope they know
what good gumbo really is.
I hope that they'll see
that it's a good product
and they want to invest in it,
'cause we really need it.
♪♪♪
Hi. I'm Carole Foster,
creator of Mee-Ma's
Louisiana gumbo bricks.
I'm seeking $200,000
in exchange
for 20% of my company.
You know, good gumbo
is really hard to find,
and so is the time it takes
to make it yourself.
I've been
a long-Haul truck driver
for the past 13 years,
so I've tasted quite a bit
of gumbo
throughout this country.
Besides being a truck driver,
I am a total gumbo geek.
A few years ago, friends asked
me to make gumbo for them
for the holidays,
but each in a different way.
And I just didn't have
time for that.
Because even for
an experienced cook like myself,
gumbo can take hours
to prepare.
So instead,
I made for them a frozen,
fully seasoned gumbo base
that they could add
whatever they like to it.
And so that's how Mee-Ma's
gumbo Bricks were born.
Now, I'd love
to have you try
some of the chicken
and seafood gumbo.
Absolutely.
(Robert) I'd love to try.
This one's seafood.
All right.
I'll try that one.
Okay.
I'll try the chicken.
That one's chicken.
I love gumbo, Carole.
The seafood one
is in the front,
chicken in the back.
Okay, I'll try the Seafood.
Okay.
(Robert) Ooh, it's got some
jalapeño kick in there.
You taste that?
All right.
It is delicious.
Thank you.
It is very good.
Who's ready to be
a gumbo geek like me?
Carole, has that okra
been frozen, that I'm eating?
That okra is frozen.
Damn, that's good.
Yeah.
That's really good.
And I want to say
to you,
Mr. Wonderful...
Yeah.
You are the okra
in my gumbo--
Slimy though it may be,
it adds character,
and it adds body,
and it adds richness.
You're describing me.
So--Exactly.
That's why I love okra.
(laughs)
I love it.
It's very tasty.
Exactly. All right.
Carole, who's the lady
in the photo?
That's my grandmother.
She lived to be 97.
She's gone to glory now,
but she's the one
who taught me
how to make gumbo.
The recipe is really
inspired by her.
When I buy the brick...
yes.
Do I add more to it,
or can I just
serve that up as is?
No. This one allows you
to put what you like in it.
So you've got the base?
This is the base.
Could we see the packages?
Sure. Sure.
What do I do
once I get the base, Carole?
You're gonna add
6 to 8 cups of water
to every gumbo brick...
thank you.
And up to 5 pounds
of meat of your choice.
And how long does it take
before I'm eating the gumbo?
45 minutes or less.
Carole, do you have sales
of your product today?
Yes, I do.
We've sold
gumbo bricks at the church.
(Lori) Wow.
However, my latest success is,
this has been selling
at various costcos in the area
for the last two years,
and I have about a half
a million dollars in sales.
Wow.
In the last two years?
Yes. But that's being
in one costco a week,
for only three days a week.
So you're setting up
and serving it
and presenting it?
Right.
As a road show item.
That's where
a lot of the money
that we've generated
over the last two
and a half years has gone to.
Wow.
Sounds like you're doing great.
Well...
you've gotten into costco.
Mm-hmm.
You're selling
half a million a year.
Yes.
What--what do you
need money for?
We need money so that we can
increase our inventory
and get it into more stores.
I currently have
a, uh, buy doc from costco.
(papers rustling)
and they are ready
and willing to accept
15 pallets of product
right now.
The problem--
15 pallets?
Correct.
It's gonna have to
be frozen, though, right?
It is frozen.
So is that
a permanent listing,
or they're gonna put it...
they're gonna put it in
as a permanent item.
As a matter of fact, we were
accepted as a permanent item
earlier this year,
and our problem was,
we couldn't keep up
with inventory.
They wanted us
to keep that freezer full.
We weren't able
to do that.
Congratulations.
What a wonderful problem
you have.
(laughs) Exactly.
Is that in costcos nationwide,
or is that in just a region?
No.
Just in the region,
here in L.A.
Can we see your order,
that you had referenced?
Yes, absolutely.
So, Carole,
you were in costco,
and you were
giving out samples...
correct.
And people were Loving it?
Yes. We sold 50,000 units.
So do you think
that you would be able
to get your gumbo
into the costcos nationwide?
Yes. Costco has
about 600 clubs nationwide.
Even if I were only able
to get into
a third of those stores,
the numbers
would be... incredible.
Well, tell us
about your costs
and what you're
selling them for.
That gumbo brick
Costs about $4 to make.
Okay, and that's
with Packaging, everything?
Correct. Out the door.
Um, we sell it to costco
for $9.99.
Can you get that cost down?
Uh, if I could
make bigger quantities.
I can only afford
to make small quantities.
You're doing great
at costco.
Mm-hmm.
Have you gotten
into any other retailers?
I've not
gotten into retail.
We really wanna
target the box clubs.
Because what--what they do when
they merchandise our product,
they put it
in a Coffin freezer
next to some $180 boxes of
lobster tails and scallops.
So we--
That's smart.
They're positioning
just right in there.
Yes, absolutely.
Well, it's a actually a platform
for all the ingredients...
absolutely. Exactly.
Which is even smarter.
Very interesting.
Yes, we've actually--
You have a commercial kitchen
doing this, right?
Uh, we have a...
commercial...
(Daymond) Co-Packer?
Co-Packer, yes.
Carole, you obviously
have a great product.
You're working hard.
It's obviously your life,
and that's a beautiful thing.
But in order to take $200,000
from an investor,
particularly me,
you've gotta be ready
to take the $200,000.
I just don't think you're ready
to take someone's money
and try to scale as big
as you wanna go yet.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
(whispers) okay.
But the gumbo's great.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
I came here because
I need the business acumen.
I don't have that.
I just know
that I make a great product.
And it's a good idea.
Um, I just--I need help
with that.
You have decent margins.
Have you talked
to anybody else
about giving them
a little bit more incentive
to make the product?
Actually, this
particular co-Packer
is willing to become
the vendor of record.
What their requirement is
is that I pay for the packaging.
And I don't
have money for that.
The packaging
for just that order alone
is about $10,000.
But you made
$100,000 this year.
Where'd the money go?
We're living off of it.
That's all we have.
We don't have anything else.
I have six brothers and sisters.
We're all
doing this business together.
We're crowded up in one house
trying to make it happen.
Okay. I-I-I got that.
As an outside investor,
how can we understand if we're
actually really making money
or losing money with you?
Yes.
I need--
I'm so--I'm so busy
with my guys, trying to
take care of my numbers.
Okay. I need help
in that--in that area.
And you will get there...
I definitely do.
And you're on a great path.
But as of now, I'm out.
(clicks teeth) okay.
Any other offers?
Carole, by asking
for $200,000 for 20%,
you're telling me
that your business
is worth a million dollars.
Yes.
Which it isn't right now.
I-I... you know,
I rarely get this kind of angst
in--in the--
in the shark tank,
'cause I'm very definitive.
The product
is so fantastic,
but the infrastructure
isn't there.
And I know that that's one of
my weaknesses. I definitely do.
Yeah, it is--It is a problem.
(Robert) Carole, I, uh...
I love gumbo.
If it's on the menu
anywhere I go,
I order it.
The spicier the Better.
Okay.
Here's the thing about food--
the margins
are actually not very good.
Once you scale, it's a very
challenging business to run.
'cause the margins
get smaller and smaller,
and you've really gotta run
a tight business.
Mm-hmm.
I'd rather see you
take your equity,
bring in an industry partner who
can guide you to that next step,
'cause you'll always
find the money.
I'm out.
I understand.
Lori, what are you gonna do?
I think she wants
more gumbo.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Lori and Kevin are Carole's
last chance to get a deal.
Lori, what are you
gonna do?
Well, I have to say,
I love you,
and I love your Gumbo.
Thank you.
I was not even hungry,
and my gumbo's almost gone.
(laughs) okay.
So that's a testament
to your gumbo.
Okay.
Um, but I'm
kind of on the fence.
Because $200,000
is a lot of money.
As Kevin said,
your valuation's at a million.
And, uh,
that's kind of hard for me.
I-I-I don't think
you're there.
This is the smartest thing
I've ever come up with to do.
It's my life.
It's all that I do.
Um, right now, um,
I'm homeless.
I'm staying with friends
right now.
And when I'm not with them,
I go over to my sister's house
and stay with them.
And if not,
I have a Van. (chuckles)
But...
where does your daughter live?
She's with me.
She's always been with me.
And by her being with me
all this time,
she knows how
to write a business plan,
she knows how to,
you know, check prices
on different items
that we use.
She's, uh,
she's been there for me.
When I decided
to become a truck driver
and reinvent myself,
I felt empowered,
because I was doing
a "Man's job."
But I was taking care of my baby
at the same time.
And that's why I'm here,
because I'm here for her.
This isn't right.
I'll put up half.
This is crazy.
What do you wanna do?
She's got a product.
I know.
Wow.
Come in with me.
So the offer is
$200,000 for 50%.
For 50%?
What you have is a lot
of drive and a great product.
The problem is
you don't have a business.
And we're gonna
fix that for you.
Absolutely. I need that.
And so we feel it's important
that we run it,
and we help to make sure
that we make you
very, very successful.
Oh, my God. (laughs)
You're not worth
a million bucks,
but we're gonna
put you in business, okay?
That's what happens
here in the shark tank
if you're willing to work.
That's what makes
America great--People like you.
Thank you so much.
Wait a minute, Carole--
do you accept their offer?
I take your offer.
You got it.
Oh...
get ready
to work your ass off.
Yes!
And make a lot of gumbo.
Yes! Yes, yes. (laughs)
Thank you.
(Lori) You're welcome.
You're welcome.
This is great.
Thank you so much.
Put you back in business.
Tell Costco we're coming.
All right.
Oh, my god, Yes.
Thank you so much.
That's terrific.
Oh, god.
Congratulations, Carole.
Thank you so much.
Awesome.
Oh, I appreciate it.
Oh, god.
I don't know what to do.
Congratulations on finding
a heart in the grinch.
(laughs) okay.
No, no, no.
That was shocking.
No, the food's good.
I'd never do this
if I didn't like
your product.
It's a great product.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate it so much.
Thank you.
Congratulations.
Oh, yes!
Aah!
She called you
a slimy something, and...
I like that.
(laughs)
What do you know?
Kevin has a heart.
Let's not go that far.
She had me from the moment
she called me slimy.
(laughs)
This deal
means everything to us.
This means that we can
actually have a real life now.
Um, it just means
that we can move forward,
and I can provide
for my daughter.